[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look then at what is on
the front pages
in the next half hour or so we'll see
what's making the headlines with the
columnist carol malone and the political
editor
of the liverpool echo liam thorpe great
to see you and
uh pleased to say have been with us
right through until midnight
for our extended news review get your
thoughts in just a moment
as ever to the front pages the eye
reporting that an
expected shortage of the fisa vaccine in
the coming days
could deal a blow to the planned
reopening on june the 21st
the time says ministers are considering
delaying the end of chronovirus
restrictions
for a month to give businesses certainty
and allow more time for people
to receive two vaccinations the metro
leads with the health secretary matt
hancock's
assertion that he didn't lie to the
prime minister and there was no
shortage of protective equipment in the
early days of the pandemic
the telegraph quoting the former prime
minister theresa may
insisting that travel restrictions she
calls incomprehensible
have rendered britain shut for business
picturing the prime minister's infant
son the daily mail splashing on boris
johnson and joe biden's meeting at the
g7 summit in cumberland the headline oh
baby what a lovin
front page of the guardian bitter
standoff over brexit
sauer's start of g7 summit carrying a
warning from the french president
emmanuel macron that nothing is
negotiable over the northern ireland
protocol
the sun offers encouragement to the
england football team as the european
championships begin
the ft has word of rising prices for
consumer goods
in the us that picture two of the
leaders in cornwall
so carol malone and liam thorpe will
come onto that breaking news about
vaccines in just a moment but first of
all
to the daily mail carol um eleven what
do you reckon about the
the body language and the bonomy between
the the two leaders
totally totally unexpected and people
might remember that it wasn't very
long ago that biden described boris as a
physical
and emotional clone of donald trump and
you know we heard all these terrible
stories
when biden was elected that you know he
he
loved the eu he hated brexit he would
always prioritize the eu
over us uh and here we are today
and i mean it is literally a love fest
one of the papers described it as a love
fest
you know boris is actually saying that
the bag has a breath
of fresh air biden's born boris a bike
and a new helmet
and look at them they're just absolutely
loving being together and this
this to me is just it's it's such good
news because i was worried about
biden when he was elected because of his
stance over the eu
i was worried that he would be you know
he would he would
he would not do us harm but he wouldn't
help us and it doesn't look like it's
going to be like that
whatever they felt about about brexit
and about
what's happening in northern ireland
currently whatever they felt about it
was hidden today it looked like they
were having a a high or time and we can
only hope that that carries on they're
going to talk about lots of things you
know he said today that someone hasn't
started yet
but they did have meetings about
northern ireland today they did discuss
things
and they looked happy when they came out
of it so hopefully
nothing is going to be a problem this
summit is going to solve
lots of problems well that's very
optimistic isn't it in fact jill biden
had
the words love on her jacket didn't she
which some have
have made a point of uh of saying what a
contrast that was to melania trump i
really don't care to you
uh on a visit to a migrant child
detention center
um but i hate to be cynical but really
for joe biden
liam this really is about reasserting
the democratic west as an important
alliance
after the trump years and in the face of
the autocrats of
china russia you name it many others so
he's gonna
want smiles on the papers isn't he
whatever happens whatever happens behind
the scenes
that's the look he wants absolutely it's
an important symbolic moment for
the new president and of course he wants
to see america and present america as
this outward-looking global nation
you know rather than the very sort of
insular protectionist
america first you know country that
donald trump was so famous for
for championing i think you know britain
is is still going to be a massive
massive ally probably more of an
important ally when you consider what's
going on in russia and china
but you know i admire carl's optimism
but i do believe that
there will be more sort of tense
difficulties regarding that northern
ireland protocol
we know of course um from patrick
mcguire's story in the times recently
about the the you know rare dimash that
was handed out
um you know a diplomatic telling off
basically from the us to the uk
about the potential risk to the good
friday agreement we know how passionate
uh joe biden is about maintaining that
good friday agreement and and
and effectively the northern ireland
protocol so i think that
that maybe didn't it got skirted over a
bit today i imagine because they wanted
this moment they wanted this important
moment where they
they get the headlines and the you know
the pictures on the front page but i
think there was probably a few thorny
discussions to come on that one
later in the week uh yes indeed lord
malik brown told us earlier that the
the reason it was done by the u.s
charges duffer earlier was in order to
park it and
and and make it all smiles today so
that's an important point but
let's move on to vaccinations shall we
which is one of the main
issues at stake here coved rebuilding
after the pandemic getting nations
through it
financial times uh says the g7 summit
will vaccinate the world
uh saying leaders of the seven advanced
economies will pledge to provide
one billion coronavirus jabs to
countries in need
as part of this plan to vaccinate the
world we heard joe biden announcing
the half billion from the us and that
breaking news tonight from the british
government
that surplus vaccines they had talked
generically about giving surplus
vaccines
now confirmation that a hundred million
will be handed over
that factors in we're told the
possibility of future
virus resistance trains or vaccine
resistance trains being detective
uh detected and this will be in addition
to the 10 billion already committed in
aid this year presumably thereby
neutering the argument about the cut and
overseas development aid money that the
the uk is now giving but are you pleased
to see this
um carol do you think that the uk is is
stepping behind this pledge
i can't yes i i am and i kind of
expected it today gordon brown was
interviewed
much earlier today and has been
interviewed in previous days and he has
he has hinted that we would give 100
million tests as he said it today
and he said that you know biden's 500
million a hundred
he said in other countries would get it
up to one billion but as he says
one billion is nowhere near enough it's
going to take 11 billion
to vaccinate the world and one hit what
gordon brown is saying
should happen at this summit is that the
all the leaders should agree to setting
up
a separate fund to make sure that
happens because one billion
isn't gonna cut it and he's saying if
you know if you're going to make a
pledge to vaccinate the world you're not
going to be able to do it with one
billion vaccinations
and you know he's kind of right and if
nothing else comes out of this summit
and that does well then this this is
this will be really good news because
we've been talking about this for a very
long time we've been talking about as
you've said on our surplus doses and all
the rest but we've never
quite made it happen biden is saying
it's gonna happen but i'll tell you the
one thing that
actually um i was a bit shocked at today
it was like
a marketing film for pfizer today
with with the boss of fives that's
standing next to joe biden at that press
conference
you know there are other vaccines apart
from pfizer and there you know we
astrazeneca seems to be wiped off the
slate one of the cheapest vaccines on
the planet
which actually does the job incredibly
well is not being talked about
only pfizer which is like 30 quid a dose
is being talked about as opposed to
astrazeneca
which is about 2.50 yeah just on that
point then just
just on that point we're also told uh by
the government today
that the prime minister will ask the g7
leaders to encourage pharmaceutical
companies
to adopt the oxford astrazeneca model of
providing vaccines
at cost for the duration of the pandemic
um
we're told also pfizer modern and
johnson and johnson have already pledged
to share 1.3 billion doses
on a non-profit basis with developing
countries so clearly liam
trying to push these other companies to
share the
oxford astrazeneca model that the
british government to be fair has been
very proud about
yeah it has and i think you know it's
it's it's like it has led by example
and we want to see kaiser and modern and
these other ones you know commit to that
and there has been some commitment on
that because we don't want to see people
getting incredibly incredibly rich off
what is you know an
absolutely now essential uh thing for
the world
so obviously that you know it's it's a
start today i agree with carol and it's
nice to hear carol quote and gordon
brown
um but he makes a really good point that
you know it needs to be a lot more than
this because at the end of the day this
is this is both the morally correct
thing to do but it's also
the entirely sensible thing to do for
everyone's interest
you know we do we can't progress as a as
a world we can't progress as
international communities
until everyone is is protected so you
know we we've seen
to our cost in this country how other
nations not being vaccinated has come
back to haunt us as well
so it was good to see that and i think
to be fair to joe biden i think he's led
on this
from even before he was elected this was
always something that he was he was
aiming for and
and america can obviously play an
enormous role in this it's
you know i think the bar the bar was
extremely low from from the last
president but
you know you would never have imagined
president trump saying anything like
that and you know he's entirely focused
on
what was going on in america so it was
it was a bit of you know to quote the
prime minister it was a bit of a breath
of fresh air to hear
the us president speaking about these
kind of you know global intentions to
help the world basically
yeah watch out i think president trump
will claim he fast-tracked the vaccine
program
in america so if he was listening to you
right now i'm not sure he'd agree but uh
to the eye now um just on on the
astrazeneca jab to
the oxford vaccine creator sarah gilbert
has told the paper that
booster dose has produced a much
stronger immune response than expected
in preliminary tests so we
watch and wait for more detail on that
but the main story obviously as you can
see is that there's a
pfizer jab shortage um hitting hopes for
the 21st of june
because of this enormous response from
under 30s i don't know how old you
you are liam probably younger than me
and carol to be fair
um but uh but i mean it's been great to
see the quick reaction festival about
the
you know this great demand from younger
people if you don't mind liam
yeah sadly i'm just over 30 but um i
have had one one of my jobs but yeah i
i have to say having reported on kobed
and
and been obviously a strong advocate of
vaccines for the last year and and
you see a lot on social media people you
know you get anti-vaxxed stuff you get
people claiming that
young people won't go for it it's been
incredibly heartening you know those
scenes that twickenham the other week of
people you know young people not sitting
in the pub on their days off they were
queuing around the block it was it was
really beautiful to see and we're now at
a situation obviously where it
it's starting to make you know the
numbers a little bit tight in terms of
the further vaccine
i think it's great that many people are
coming forward and hopefully we can get
to a point where where they can all get
their jobs because at the end of the day
this isn't just about
people getting seriously ill and dying
we know loads of young people who've got
covered who are still suffering with
long covet with those you know those
really debilitating symptoms so we
really do need to get everyone
vaccinated i think that's become clear
what we are seeing is rising cases
we hopefully won't see that that serious
surge in hospital admissions but if we
do start to see that bit of extra
pressure on the nhs
we know that that's going to roll over
into other treatments so i think
everyone of every age getting vaccinated
is absolutely essential right now
and carol how do you um how do you feel
about the monday announcement from the
prime minister
about whether there might be a delay a
month we saw in one of the papers
two to four weeks suggested do you think
it's sensible to try and get
more people vaccinated or are you all
gung-ho to go
i'm cut you know i'm kind of i'm i'm in
between two
two stills here because yes i think we
should be going because people
are are getting the virus more people
are getting it now and 95
91 percent of all new covert cases are
the delta variant
but they're not dying from it fewer
people are dying
all the time hospitals are not
overwhelmed with this this is going to
be covered it's going to become
like a flu and and if that's the case we
have to open the country for business
you wouldn't keep the country closed for
for a bad dose of flu so why are we
doing it
for for this you know a two week delay
is not going to be the end of the world
but it really
has to be the last one and and you know
if
we're saying that yes covert cases are
increasing but hospital and the hospital
admissions are increasing slightly
but they're not serious they're not
serious cases
nowhere near as many people are dying
now so you know we have to accept that
kermit is going to be part of our lives
and we can't keep the airlines industry
closed the travel is
closed as theresa may says in one in the
telegraph tomorrow
that you know we're closed for business
this country and we can't be we have to
reopen for business
yeah we're going to talk about that in
more detail after the break in fact just
wanted to point out the i like the times
yesterday
talked about plans to fast-track wedding
uh backlog of 200
000 couples so perhaps talk about that
too theresa may's evidence and the
evidence too of matt hancock
does the health secretaries claim that
there was no shortage of ppe early in
the pandemic stand up to scrutiny back
with that in just a moment
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now carol malone
and liam thorpe to the metro we go liam
you kicked this off hancock's half hour
was uh
well over that four and a half hours
nearly uh some really important evidence
tackled what did you make of it
yeah um i thought it was pretty pretty
offensive really i thought there was a
lot of the health sector trying to
trying to rewrite history obviously as
it says on the on the metro there that
probably the big
headline was him claiming that there was
not really a ppe shortage that put
health
workers um you know in in the front line
in danger and i think i think everyone
knows that's not true we saw pictures
of nurses of carers wearing beam bags i
personally have spoken to
hospital workers who didn't have what
they what they required and i know many
other journalists have as well i thought
he was selective
in in his evidence he quoted an nao
report which uh which
to to back up his claim but that same
report he helpfully missed out a bit
which said that there was a shortage of
ppe and that
there was a really difficult situation
for frontline workers the public
accounts committee also
said there was an appalling situation
regards ppp so that was just
one of many areas where i don't think he
was quite sticking to the truth
another one was on was on the lockdown
situation and another one on care homes
so
i think a lot of people will have been
watching that being extremely frustrated
and seeing the health secretary trying
to wriggle out of things really
you've got 20 seconds carol he blamed
everyone but himself for every cock-up
that has happened during this pandemic
the worst of all
being the care homes trying to blame
care workers for bringing the virus
into the care homes and killing patients
in there that was shocking
even for hancock